Speaker 1: Anti-vaccine so-called expert Sherri
Tenpenny is again spreading fear and promulgating
disinformation about the COVID 19 vaccine. She is
now warning everyone that is close to you is soon
going to die from the COVID vaccine, not from
COVID, from the COVID vaccine. Sherri Tenpenny
is now warning about a tsunami of deaths in
2023. She says by the end of this calendar year,
the year of the Lord 2023, every one of us will
know five, maybe ten or more people who have died
from the COVID vaccine. Okay. Let's listen to what
she had to say. This is very instructive in terms
of fear mongering and so many other things.
Speaker 4: Let's listen now. We're seeing the
tsunami of deaths. Tsunami I've been talking about
since the beginning of 21. Millions of people are
going to die. You know, when Judy Mikovits came
out on Plandemic at the beginning of that and by.
Speaker 1: The way, that was one of the biggest
nonsense propaganda films. Plandemic and Mikovits
It's crazy to even mention it.
Speaker 4: That
that more than 50 million people are going
to die. And everybody was like, Whoa!
And when they started interviewing me and I and
they asked me, what did I think about that number,
I said, It's way too low. Oh, it's going to be
much more than 50 million people in America alone.
And we're already starting to see it.
Speaker 1: We're not.
Speaker 4: So the tsunami of deaths is
coming. It's already here. And I believe
that what's happening now is is starting
to happen now is the tsunami of regrets
of the people that fell for the lies,
the fear, friends and family members and
parents and children. And all they did
to your grandchildren just could not be
told otherwise. But now that people are dying
like flies, I mean, my business partner has
83 close people in his life that have died.
Speaker 1: You know, most the truth is most
people don't have 83 people in their lives that
they are close to. This is like a separate issue,
but these are obvious lies.
Speaker 4: 83.
Speaker 1: Yeah. No.
Speaker 4: It's the beginning.
And I predict that by the end of this year,
every person in this room and every person
listening behind here is going to know a minimum
of five, probably ten or more close friends and.
Speaker 1: Figure you don't have as many
friends as her business partner. So you'll
have only 5 to 10 people die.
Speaker 4: Members that have
died from these shots.
Speaker 1: Right.
So I want to remind everybody, and this is so
controversial every time people say David, is
Sherri Tenpenny a doctor? Is she not a doctor? And
when I explain it, people get mad. Sherry Tenpenny
is not a medical doctor. She is an osteopathic
physician. Now, whenever I make that distinction,
people start writing in, including osteopath,
saying, David, you shouldn't act as though that
is less than being an MD. I'm not saying anything.
I'm just telling you she's not an M.D. She's an
osteopathic physician, and her claims have no
scientific basis. It doesn't mean every osteopath
believes the things Sherri Tenpenny believes. I'm
not saying that at all. All I'm telling you is
actual medical doctors have debunked her claims.
Health organizations have debunked your claims.
Many osteopathic have also debunked her claims.
But in the sense that osteopathic physicians
are doctors, she is indeed a doctor. Now, if she
sounds familiar, and this is really the big point
I want to make. It's because we have listened
to her predictions in the past, and of course,
none of them have come to pass. What I would like
is accountability for these people when they make
these predictions. Let's remember and then we can
follow up and say, hey, that stuff didn't happen.
Because remember when she said this last year?
Speaker 4: The more shots you get, the more the
more you destroy your immune system and the
faster that happens. And it's anticipated.
The German data says that by the end of
2022, every fully vaccinated person over
the age of 30 may have the equivalent of full
blown vaccine induced immune suppressed AIDS.
Speaker 1: Ladies and gentlemen, as a fully
vaccinated person over the age of 30, I am here
today to tell you I do not have full blown vaccine
induced immune suppressed AIDS. I do have a little
neck pain from a weird movement I did at the gym
three days ago, but I don't have full blown AIDS.
So the point is, it's fear, fear, fear. And we're
going to talk about this later. I can't believe
I'm saying these words. But later on in the show,
I'm going to talk to you about Tucker Carlson,
fear mongering about a space vagina. I know it
sounds insane, but it's what it is. They have to
induce fear. Fear generates the environment they
need in order to then sell you something, whether
it's tickets to an event or a product or liquid,
liquid, silver, whatever it is they sell you.
And then there's no follow up and there's no
accountability. We have to hold these people
accountable for their endless failed predictions.
This is yet another one of those. And if you want
to if you're listening today and you want to see
what this looks like when this woman makes these
claims. We'll have all of these clips on our
YouTube channel, YouTube.com slash The David
Pakman Show and on our Instagram, which you can
find by searching Instagram for David Pakman show.